german foreign minister annalena berbak
is now the host for a flurry of
high-level diplomacy she returned home
from a trip to ukraine earlier this week
and is now chairing a meeting of foreign
ministers of the g7 it'll be followed by
nato and european union meetings to try
and increase pressure on russia and
support for ukraine
one country though is causing major
problems hungary's prime minister viktor
orban re-elected last month opposes
further energy sanctions the eu wants a
ban on russian oil imports by the end of
the year even though hungary and
slovakia will be given exemptions orban
is still threatening to veto the
question is
if hungary
shows bigger solidarity to
uh its european allies and partners or
it shows bigger solidarity with
putin's russia so i'm i very much hope
that in the end hungary will make the
right choice because it would be
really impossible to square their uh
participation in eu and nato if they
continue to
block this this sanctions because
because of special ties with with putin
if you drive about three hours from
where the g7 foreign ministers are
meeting along germany's baltic coast
brings you here to lubman this is where
the nord stream pipelines which run from
russia to germany terminate
this place sums up what's been achieved
by the west in recent months
unprecedented steps like the mothballing
of nordstrom 2 something the u.s had
been demanding for years
but the other pipeline nordstrom 1 is
still operating it delivers 55 billion
cubic meters of natural gas to germany a
year
an indication of the vast sums europe
continues to pay to russia for its
energy james bay's al jazeera northern
germany